I want to take up in Volume 3 in July the 16th 1900. The subject's chastisement will serve for
the good of creatures and for that I want to give you Psalm 145 verse 17 that God only ever acts
out of love and that's because God is love. This morning my adorable Jesus was not coming.
Louisa says, "After much waiting he came and he told me, my daughter the best thing for you
is to commend yourself to me and to my will so that by commending yourself to me since I am peace
even if you saw me send chastisements you would remain at peace that Isaiah 26-3 you will
give him in perfect peace whose mind is stayed on you because he trusts in you and he said you
won't feel any disturbance and Louisa said, "our lord you always come to this to chastisements."
You see the problem is even with the amount that she has been receiving from the Lord
she doesn't see what this terrible 20th century is going to actually do and the horrors it's going
to produce. So she says, "plicate yourself once and for all so that there will be no more scourges.
Besides I cannot commend myself to your will in this regard." Now here's Louisa showing a problem
that we have in lots of ways and that is that you can agree with God's will in many things and
there are some things and you just feel, "no, I can't do this." And Jesus said, "I cannot
placate myself." In other words, this is the job of the victim soul. What would you say if you saw
someone naked who instead of covering these nakedness paid attention to adorning himself
with trinkets leaving the parts most necessary exposed to nakedness? And Louisa said, "I'd be
horrified at seeing him and I'd certainly blame him." And Jesus said, "well then that's the way
souls are. They are completely naked." That means the garment of grace is not there. So I want to
give you Genesis 3.10 that after Adam and Eve sinned in the Garden of Eden that they had become
spiritually naked and you're told that they had been physically naked before that and it wasn't
a problem but now that shame and guilt had moved in the physical nakedness was a problem. I also want
to give you Revelation 1616 where Saint John is warning the early Christians about the second
coming of Jesus and he says to them, "make sure you are not found with your clothes off." Now he's
not talking about streaking. He's saying, "don't you face death or judgment if the garment of grace
isn't there." So Jesus says that here in 1900 that souls are completely naked, they've no more
virtues to cover them. Therefore it is necessary that I beat them, scourge them, deprive them,
so as to make them come back to their senses. Now do you remember the prodigal son in Luke 15?
After all the sinning that he did, you're told that when he decided to return to the father that
he had come to his senses, okay? And a little bit earlier you have the deliverance of the demoniac,
the terrible demoniac, and after he had been delivered and healed by Jesus, you're then told
that he was sitting at the feet of Jesus in his right mind he had come to his senses.
So the reason for the chastisements then is to make them come back to their senses and realize
the nakedness of their souls, okay? Now there's a very telling piece in Revelation 3, 14 to 22 when
the Spirit is speaking to the Church of Laodicea. They were a very wealthy town and they had all
kinds of things and the Lord told them that they were not only blind but spiritually naked as well
and they were poor and pitiless and they didn't even know. And I think that's the condition of
the modern world today. And they have to realize their nakedness because this is more necessary
than the nakedness of the body. But if I did not do this he said I would be paying attention to
trinkets like the person you blamed which are the things that refer to the body and I would not be
paying attention to the most essential thing which is the soul, the only thing that's going to last
forever which they have reduced to being so monstrous as to no longer be recognizable. Isn't that really
frightening? Okay I want to give you Isaiah chapter 2 verses 6 to 22 and Isaiah chapter 3 verses 16 to 24.
So after this it seemed that Jesus had a little rope in his hands and passing it behind my neck
he bound me and then bound his neck in the same rope. In other words this is this very strong bond
of union. He did the same to the heart and the hands and by which he seemed to bind me completely
to his will. So he's drawing Louisa deeper and deeper into the union they already have. So July
the 17th 1900 Louisa gives a relief to Jesus. Having received communion I did not see blessed
Jesus as I usually do. After waiting a long time I felt I was going outside myself and I found him.
As I saw him he said to me daughter I was waiting for you to be able to rest a little bit in you
but I cannot take any more or please give me a relief. Now a relief usually means that she will do
some reparation and save souls. Immediately I took him in my arms to content him she said and I saw
that he had a deep wound in his shoulder which aroused compassion and repugnance at the same time.
So he rested for a few minutes and then after a brief rest I looked and I saw that that wound
was almost healed. So amid amazement and stupid factions she said and seeing him more relieved I
plucked up the courage and I said blessed Lord my poor heart is tormented by a fear that you don't
love me anymore. She goes on and on about this. I fear I have encouraged her indignation and this
is why you no longer come as before. Now she's been told endlessly it's because he's chastising.
You do not pour your bitterness into me and you no longer give me my good which is suffering
and by denying me this you come to deny me yourself because he comes frequently when she's
suffering the crucifixion so she knows what has to happen to have him there. Oh please she said
give peace to a poor heart tell me assure me swear to me do you love me do you continue to love me?
He said yes yes yes I love you. I love that response yes yes yes. And Louisa said how can I be sure of
this since when one really loves someone whatever he wants one wants to give them. But I say to you
do not chastise the people and you chastise them. I say pour your bitterness into me and you don't
pour it. On the country it seems that this time you're going too far. Wow isn't it amazing to have
that kind of familiarity with God. So how can I rely on your loving me? She said and he said my daughter
you take into account the chastisements I send but those which I hold back you take not into account
at all how many more chastisements I would have sent how many more slaughters and how much more blood
I would have caused to be shed if I had no regard for those few who love me and whom I love with
a special love. And then after this it seemed that Jesus that on his way to go there where slaughters
of human flesh were occurring. I wanted to follow him but it was not given to me to do it so to my
highest sorrow she was back to herself. So July the 18th 1900 the sins of the people fall back
upon themselves and cause their ruin. In other words we make the chastisments and we draw the
chastisments to ourselves. As I was in my usual state I saw my adorable Jesus for just a little
all afflicted inside of my heart. Now inside of my heart is Luke 17 21 the kingdom of God is within
you and one Corinthians 3 16 no you not that you are the temple of the living God and at the spirit
of God dwells in you. I also saw many people committing many sins she said these sins were setting out
towards me to come and wound my beloved Lord even inside my heart but Jesus would push them away
from himself and they would come to fall upon the people themselves and in falling upon them they
would form their own ruin changing into many kinds of scourges over the people such as to
horrify the hardest hearts. In other words our sins cause our own ruin. Now that's not news all you
got to do is read the whole of the Bible and it's telling you that all the time but we know this
even from observation we say that person is their own worst enemy. We actually cause the problems
by what we do the wrong decisions we make and then all grieved Jesus said my daughter to what extent
the blindness of men reaches while they try to wound me they wound themselves with their own hands
Matthew 15 14 and Revelation 3 17. So July the 19th 1900,
Louisa offers herself to suffer so that the people can be spared. So this is Louisa doing her role
as victim soul. This morning after spending the whole night and a great part of the morning
waiting for my adorable Jesus he was not gaining to come. So tired of waiting him I tried to go
out of my usual state thinking that it might no longer be the will of God and she's been told
endlessly that it is the will of God. Almost impatient while I was trying to go out of it my good Jesus
moved within my heart there's your Luke 17 21 again just barely making himself seem looking at me in
silence. Impatient as I was I said to him my good Jesus how can you be so cruel can there be a greater
cruelty than this abandoning a soul prey to the ruthless tyrant of love that makes her live in
continuous agony or how you've changed from being loving to cruel. Now this is her Italian side
being all emotional. As I was saying this I saw many mutilated members of people before me and so
what the Lord does there is he simply distracts her by letting her see what's actually going on.
Our Lord how much mutilated human flesh how much bitterness and pains would not have been a lesser
cruelty if you had satisfied yourself in this body of mine by tearing it into as many shreds as you
want and as many divisions you have caused in these members. Would it not have been a lesser evil
to see only one suffered than many poor people? Now that's the language that you get in John
chapter 11 verses 45 to 50 where the high priest said that it was better for one man to die than
for the whole people. Well the high priest was right and was wrong at the same time. It was in fact
right for the one man Jesus to die for our redemption but it was not going to prevent the death of
the nation. The death of the nation came in AD 70 to 132 AD and which they ended up all being
expelled. The ones who survived ended up being expelled from the country or enslaved. So Louisa
said while I was saying this Jesus continued to fix his eyes on me as if he were struck. I can't
tell whether he was grieved too and he said to me yet this is only the beginning of the game.
This is still nothing compared to what is to come. Now when he says the game he says the drama that's
going on between human beings and God and how they are trying to take over and be God themselves.
Okay and we're going to hear more and more and more about this. So having said this he flew away
from my side she said. So July the 21st 1900 is the need for purification. Now if you are taking
the divine will as spirituality seriously you have to know that if the Lord sees that you're
serious as distinct from anybody else seeing it then you will be letting yourself in for a long
period of purification because we have no idea about the holiness and the purity of God. We've
none whatsoever and he has to purify us more and more and more and more for him to be able
to tolerate us because of his holiness. So Louisa says after spending one day being dozy and so
sleepy that I couldn't understand myself having received communion I felt I was going outside of
myself but I could not find my highest and only good. So I began to go around and round in delirium.
While doing this I felt there was someone in my arms completely veiled in such a way that I could
not see who he was. So unable to refrain any longer I tore that veil and I saw my longed for good.
On seeing Jesus I felt I wanted to burst into complaints and nonsense but in order to break
my impatience and my delirium Jesus gave me a kiss. I absolutely love that. There's nothing
shuts you off quicker than a kiss. There's no room to talk. That's the song of songs one one let him
kiss me with the kisses of his mouth. That kiss infused life into me and also calm and it broke my
impatience so much so that I was unable to say anything more and then forgetting all my miseries
now he's been telling her to do that you see and I have many she said I remembered the poor people
and I said to Jesus placate yourself bear so many people torment so cruel. Let us go together
where such things are happening that we may comfort and console those poor Christians who are in
such a bad state and he said my daughter I do not want to take you for your heart would not bear
seeing such a harrowing slaughter. He said I don't want to take you because you're not able for it
and luisa said oh lord how is it that you've permitted this and he said it's necessary absolutely
for the sake of purgation in every place because in the field sowed by me that is in the church
okay this is really sad really really sad Jesus said it's absolutely necessary because
there must be purgation in every place because in the field sowed by me weeds and thorns have grown
so much as to become trees in other words the evil has matured and these thorny trees do nothing
but inundate my field which is the church with poisonous and pestilent waters to the point that
if some ear of grain remains intact it receives nothing but punctures and stench so much so that's
impossible for more ears to germinate first because they lack the ground which is occupied
by so many noxious plants second because of the continuous punctures that they receive which give
them no peace so this is the necessity for slaughter to root out many bad plants now that's revelation
1118 and it's not funny it says I will destroy the destroyers of the earth so he says the reason
for what's going on is to root out so many bad plants and of shedding blood to purge my field of
those poisonous and pestilent waters therefore do not want to grow sad at the beginning does an
awful lot more to see because not only there but I have sent chastisement but in all other places
purgation is needed that means there's going to be a world war now let me just give you a little
thing on that and that is that during the years 1878 to 1903 and we're only at 1900 we have Pope
Leo XIII and I think he's the one who wrote the encyclical of errors in which you tried to point
out what was wrong with communism and Marxist atheism and materialism and rationalism and modernism
and all the rest of it and the pope that came after him pious the tenth absolutely condemned them
we're told that he died of a broken heart at the beginning of the war
so louisa said who could say the consternation of my heart in hearing these words of jesus
so again I insisted that I wanted to go and see but jesus not listening to me disappeared
left alone I took my way to go there this is very interesting whose will is it it's louisa's
he didn't want to take her there so if she makes an attempt to go there by herself
she has to take the consequences but first I found an angel who would make me go back
and then I found purging souls to the point that I was forced to return into myself this is very
interesting because this is louisa's will and the angel will always do god's will the bible tells
us from cover to cover that the angels do god's will and when there's no human beings on the planet
that's willing to do it the angels will do it so if you go back to the book of numbers chapter 22
verses 22 to 35 you get the story of balam's donkey and balam was the prophet and he should have
been doing god's will but he wasn't and so what happened was at the angel appeared and the donkey
could see him because the donkey wasn't spiritually blind and balam was beating up the donkey until
the end the donkey said to why are you beating me up it you have the problem you're the one that's
against god's will and so the angel absolutely insisted on him going back and he had to do god's
will so here's louisa saying that the angel also prevented her from going forward I just think
that's fascinating so july the 25th 1900 there's no cruelty at all in jesus everything is love because
god is love one john four seven to seventeen this morning my adorable jesus oh i better give you
amos three seven and isiah sixty four ten for what we're going to read because she gets an image
of the concentration camps in the second world war very very interesting ama amos three seven says
that the lord never does anything without showing his prophets first so this morning my adorable
jesus came and made me see a machine in which it seemed that many human members were being crushed
as well as something like two signs of chastisements in the air chastisements that struck terror
now it seems that she's looking at the ovens in dakau and Auschwitz and places like that
where human beings were little born to ashes the two signs of chastisements in the air that brought
terror was the atom bomb that finished the second world war and it did go on to two cities
but blessed jesus seeing me so in bitter said to me my daughter let me move what so much afflicts us
away from us for a little while let's cheer each other by playing a little bit now the child
likeness of this and the innocence of this is something that modern people won't appreciate
because they've lost her who can say what passed between jesus and me in this game she said the
finesses of love the stratagems the kisses and the caresses that we gave each other however
in other words love had to be poured out on both sides to express itself my beloved jesus surpassed
me because being very weak i would faint so much so that unable to contain within myself what he
was giving to me i said my beloved enough enough i can take no more i faint now that song of songs
to five enough for now she said and then wanting to scold me because of my words of the other day
jesus said to me sweetly let me hear your complaints tell me now am i cruel has my love changed into
cruelty for you and louisa said i was all blushing and i said no larger not cruel when you come but
when you don't come there you've got two lovers talking to each other and so he has poured out his
love and he says now are you going to tell me i'm cruel and so louisa never lets him away with it
and she said no you're not cruel when you come you're cruel when you don't come lovers have to be
together they have to be united so smiling at my words jesus said you're still keep saying that i
am cruel when i do not come no no there can be no cruelty in me at all everything is love i know
that if it is as you say my very being cruel is greater love okay sam one four five seven team
verse 17 now throughout these writings you'll hear jesus saying that love is a tyrant it demands
absolutely everything in the hours of the passion louisa explains how love was a tyrant for jesus
and that love demanded a greater passion from him than either our sins or as what louisa calls the
passion of the jews could actually give to him and it was his own divine love that was demanding
absolutely everything from him so louisa has got to imitate him so she also therefore has to experience
the tyranny of love so july the 27 1900 louisa sees attacks on the the church so again this is
amos three seven and isiah 64 10 i was all worried about my miserable state especially that it might
no longer be the will of god she keeps that up and she will continue and i considered my scarce
suffering and his continuous privation is the sure sign of this now while i was wearing out my little
brain over this and i struggled to snap out of it now that's correcting because she's been told
that it's not the way she's thinking my always good jesus made himself seem like a flash saying
to me now jesus is not going to give her more and more insight into the privation until she
learns to handle it better my daughter what do you want me to do tell me i will do what you want
isn't that what human beings like to hear as such an unexpected proposal i didn't know what to say
she said i felt such confusing over the fact that blessed jesus would have to do what i wanted
whereas we're supposed to be doing what he wants while it is i who must do what he wants she said i
remained silent so seeing that i wasn't saying anything he escaped like a flash and i running
after him found myself outside of myself i didn't find him so i wandered around the earth the heavens
the stars calling him with my voice with my singing thinking to myself that on hearing my voice and
my singing blessed jesus would be wounded and i would find him with certainty so this is sam 63
my god you know everything in me is crying out for you it's also the song of songs chapter five verse
six where the bride will do anything to try and find the bride groom again now while wandering around
i saw a cruel torment that continues in the war in china i saw churches knocked down images of
our lord thrown to the ground and this is nothing yet that which frightened me the most was to see
that if now this is done by barbarians that means people of no faith people who don't understand
christianity by secular by that she means society as distinct from the church and later it will be
done by false religious who've removing their masks and letting themselves be known for what
they are uniting with the open enemies of the church now this is very interesting because the
infiltration of the church by communism starts at the beginning of the century and after sometime
then some of the priests and bishops and cardinals are sucked into both Freemasonry and communism
and to this very day we have that problem in the church and therefore we have what our blessed lady
said to don goby ecclesiastical masonry in other words men who have got the highest jobs in the
church actually working against the church it's untrinkable for us at the bottom at the letter
so she says that false religious will be destroying the church uniting it with the
open enemies of the church they will launch such an attack as to be incredible to the human mind
oh how many more cruel torments she said it seems that they have sworn among themselves to end
it with the church now the problem with priests and bishops and cardinals is that they can destroy
the church from within enemies like Freemasons and secularists and communists and atheists and
all the rest they can attack it from without but the communists said that the structure of the church
was so perfect that it had to be destroyed from within but the lord will take revenge over them
by destroying them that's revelation 11 18 i will destroy the destroyers of the world so there will
be blood on one side and blood on the other then i found myself inside a garden the garden usually
represents the church and inside that there was a crowd of people in the appearance of dragons
now here's your ecclesiastical masonry of vipers and other raging beasts which devastated that garden
now unfortunately a century later we know exactly what louise is saying it's really sad sad sad sad
they've done terrible damage to the church so i want to give you our blessed lady and last
select in 1846 said that this would happen that she said cardinals bishops and priests are going
taking many of the laity with them and she described the damage that was being done i want to give
you isiah 28 from verse 7 to 22 i want to give you matthew 15 verses 1 to 12 where jesus is addressing
the scribes and Pharisees who are the church leaders during the time of the incarnation i say
church just to make it familiar to you leaders of the jewish religion and one of the things he said
was that these people honor me with lip service but their heart is far from me in other words this
isn't real service of god they're just simply using these positions and then you've matthew 23
where jesus pulls the masks off the scribes and Pharisees and Sadducees and tells them who they
are completely and what judgment awaits them so here you have religious people in the appearance
of dragons vipers and other raging beasts which devastated the guard and then they went outside
forming the ruin of the people now while i was seeing this i found my beloved lord in my arms
and i said finally you have let yourself be found are you my really my dear jesus and he
said yes yes i am your jesus and i wanted to tell him to spare so many people but he was not paying
attention to this at all and he said my daughter i'm quite tired let us go into your bed to rest and
if you want me to remain with you in other words we're not discussing this let's go back and into
a different environment altogether and i fearing that he might leave kept silent allowing him to
fall asleep okay so that's your mark for 38 jesus asleep in the boat with the storm all around him
and then after a little while he reentered into my interior leaving me reassured yes but highly
afflicted so july the 30th 1900 louisa stops the sword of justice again this is amos 37
and isiah 6410 i spent one night and one day being restless louisa said from the very beginning i felt
i was going outside of myself without being able to find my adorable jesus so what's the point in
going outside of yourself if you're not going to find him i could see nothing but things that
struck terror and flight in me i could see that a fire was flaring up in israeli now fire represents
god our god is a consuming fire fire represents hell the fires of hell fire represents war fire
represents trials and difficulties and all kinds of things so the fire is most likely at least the
beginnings of war global find out the text will tell us i could see that a fire was flaring up in
israeli now it just so happens that fascism was beginning and was going to be one terrible problem
for israeli and another one had flared up in china which of course is marxist communism
a little by little uniting together they were blending into one that is true fascism and communism
united in this fire i could see the king of italy who had suddenly died by a trick
and this was the means to ignite and expand the fire so for moseley need to take over
and fascism to rule italy they got rid of the king of italy we'll meet him again in purgatory
in some i could see a revolt i could see a chumult i could see killing of people and after having
seen these things i felt i was inside of myself and felt my soul being tortured to the point of
feeling i was dying more so since i could not see my adorable jesus and then after much waiting
he made himself seen with the sword in his hand in the act of throwing it over the people
okay now the sword can represent war the sword can represent a divine punishment on the people so
i want to give you revelation six four revelation 13 10 revelation 19 15 to 19 so this is jesus
returning and he's coming as a warrior so the sword sometimes the sword is the word of god as
well but if he's throwing a sword over the people it's not the word of god he had a sword in his hand
in the act of throwing it over the people all frightened of being a little daring i took the
sword in my hand telling him lord what are you doing don't you see how many disasters will occur
if you throw this sword what grieves me the most is that i see you're putting italy in the middle
fascism was in the middle and lord placate yourself and have pity on your images so images is roman's
a 29 and if you say that you love me spear me this bitter sorrow and while saying this i held on to
that sword as tightly as i could now she's using her office of victim soul here and i want you to
remember abraham in genesis 18 interceding for sodom and gomara and he gets bolder and bolder
as it goes along by that i mean more courageous heaving aside all afflicted jesus said to me my
daughter let it go let it fall on the people that sword would mean that the wars would begin
and it's only 1900 he said let it go and louisa holding it more tightly said i cannot let it go
i do not have the heart to do it and he said have i not told you many times that i am forced not to
let you see anything otherwise i'm not free to do it i want and while saying this he lowered his arm
with the sword and placed himself in an act of calming his fury okay so that war was going to be
1914 to 1918 not now so notice the power that the victim souls have the extraordinary power to
intercede effectively for us after a little while jesus disappeared from me and i was left with
the fear that who knows without letting me see it he might pull the sword away from me louisa kept
it she wouldn't let it go she's a brave little lady so august the first 1900 the humanity of jesus
is the mirror of the divinity and of course we're having more chastisement 1900 is the time for
chastisements my adorable jesus continues to come only very few times and for a short time
this morning i felt all annihilated and i almost did not dare to go and search of my highest good
but always kind he came and wanting to infuse trust in me he told me my daughter there is no one
who can stand before my majesty and purity notice the no one rather all are forced to be
terrified and struck by the thunderbolt of my sanctity that's what happens souls who die in
mortal sin struck by the thunderbolt of god's sanctity so i want to give you asiah 35 verses
8 to 10 i want to give you hebrews 12 14 revelation 21 27 and revelation 22 15 man would almost want
to flee from me because as you saw with adam in genesis chapter 3 as soon as he sinned he wanted
to hide from god because his misery is such and so great that he doesn't have the courage to stand
before the divine being and here's why giving the field to my mercy i took on my humanity which
tempering the rays of the divine so that he could be seen merely as man if i can put it that way
that is the means to infuse in man trust and courage to come to me placing himself before my
humanity which spreads temperate rays of the divine man has the good or the privilege of being able
to purify sanctify and even divinize himself in my very deified humanity i think that's absolutely
brilliant the church has told us that we can only go to god through jesus through him with him and in
him the holy spirit when he comes into us it does four things he first of all cleanses that's the
big cleanse then he purifies that means you go after the roots of the plants and then he sanctifies
and then he glorifies and the spirit can come because jesus has made it possible through his
divine human being therefore you should remain always before my humanity keeping it as a mirror
that's two Corinthians three eighteen through which you will clean all of your stains it's only by
looking at him that we know what sin is not only this but as a mirror through which by reflecting
yourself in it you will acquire beauty and little by little you will keep adorning yourself with my
own likeness in fact it is a property of a mirror to make an image appear within it similar to that
of the one who is reflecting himself in it if such is the material mirror it is much more so
with the divine because my humanity serves man as a mirror in order to reflect my divinity and here's
how all the goods come to man from my humanity so it is one to give you a remembrance of Moses
up Mount Sinai for 40 days and 40 nights fasting and praying and being in deep communion with God
and when he came down the mountain the glory of God was all over him to such a degree that nobody
could look at him even Aaron the high priest couldn't tolerate this extraordinary glow that was on
Moses's face and so he had to cover his face to let the people be able to tolerate him it's amazing
to me that none of the people including Aaron got the idea that they too could go up the mountain
and that they too could become like God so while Jesus was saying this Louisa said I felt such
trust being infused into me now this is absolutely essential to our relationship with God
Saint Teresa Blissio is famous for having said that you will receive from God exactly as much as
you trust him to receive. Frost is absolutely basic to every relationship so I felt such trust
being infused into me that the thought came to me of wanting to talk to him about the chastisements
now we stop there for a second Jesus will explain as we go on these writings that his word is creative
so as soon as he says something it comes into being so he's talking to Louisa about trusting
God and the trust is infused into her as the words are being said if the Lord says to you repent he
actually gives you the power to do it if he says forgive he gives you the power to do it his word
is creative so now Louisa wants to distract him by talking about the chastisement and she says
who knows he might grant me an audience and I might reach the point of placating him completely but
while I was about to do this he disappeared like a flash and running after him my soul found herself
outside of myself so she was in and out of the body experience but I was unable to find him
anymore and to my highest sorrow I saw people entering prisons others sectarians now what she
calls sectarians we would call Marxist communists and Leninists and all of these people going out
to make attempts on the lives of other kings and other leaders now this is very important
they've managed to get rid of the king of Italy because the communists were completely
determined to get rid of all royalties and all royal houses and so on they wanted to take over
and they wanted to run the world in their own particular way and of course when they take over
in Russia they killed the Tsar as well so that's what they want to get rid of all the ruling houses
of the world and set up their own hellish systems so she said I saw many people entering prisons
and they want to kill off the leaders I saw that they were consumed with rage because they lacked
the means to come out into the midst of the people and make a slaughter so at this particular point
God has not given them the freedom to move and so they can't move so they're like caged animals
and they can rage and rage but they can do nothing because they're powerless yet their time will
come unfortunately it was 1914 to 18 for the terrible war and in 1917 you had the Bolshevik
revolution the first of them there was two of them and of course hell on earth then for everybody
in what came to be known as the Soviet Union so August the third 1900 and here we're going to be
talking about nothingness with a very important message as I was in my usual state I was longing
and searching for my loving Jesus then after I waited for him for a long time he came and he told
me my daughter why do you look for me outside of yourself Luke 17 21 the kingdom of God is within you
one Corinthians 3 16 no you not that you are the temple of the living God and the spirit of God
dwells in you Matthew 6 6 go into your private room shut the door and there you'll meet your father
in secret okay so he said don't you realize you'll find me much more easily inside of yourself than
roaming around the earth and the heaven searching for me when you want to find me enter into yourself
which is exactly Matthew 6 6 go deep into your nothing and there without yourself in the most
tiny circle of your nothing you will find the foundations that the divine being laid in you
wow go into your nothingness and you'll find him because he only works with our nothingness he
created this out of nothing the safest place on the planet is your nothingness Satan won't find you
there but God will so not only that you will see the foundations that the divine being laid within
you as well as the factories it has raised in you go and look and see he said I looked and I saw
solid foundations and very high walls that reached up to the heavens but that which stupefied me was
to see that the Lord had done all this beautiful work upon my nothing and the walls were all walled
up with no openings I see the song of song says that my beloved is a garden enclosed and a fountain
sealed up one could see only one opening in the vault and this one corresponded to heaven
and in this opening our Lord dwelled upon a stable column that rose out of the foundations
formed over nothing now while I was looking all stupefied blessed Jesus said the foundations
formed over nothing mean that the divine hand operates where there is nothing would you please
underline that in green white and gold it is extremely important because by the end of volume
three and we're almost there if you haven't caught on to the fact that the place that we need to stay
is in our nothingness then we haven't learned much in these three volumes Jesus said the foundations
formed over nothing mean that the divine hand operates where there is nothing and it never mixes
the divine works with the material because God is pure spirit the walls without openings around
mean that the soul must have no response or exchange with earthly things in such a way
that there may be no danger that even a little bit of dust may enter because everything is walled
up well the Lord seals everything and as you go into the higher volumes he'll talk about sealing
the only correspondence that these walls allow is with heaven that is from nothing to heaven
from heaven to nothing and this is the meaning of the opening made in the vault the stability of the
column means that the soul is so stable and good that there's no contrary wind that can move her
and my dwelling upon it is a sure sign that the work done is fully divine i want to give you
Ephesians chapter three verses 16 to 21 you must be grounded in love you must be built on love you
must be rooted in love you must reach our fullness in love okay and i want to give you a Philippians
one six the work that the Lord has begun in you he will complete if he's allowed so
August the ninth 1900 we're talking about our desires and intentions again this is an absolute
foundational teaching and it is essential for us so this morning my adorable Jesus was not coming
so i waited for a long time then he made himself seen for just a little and he told me just as a
musical instrument in other words something that produces different notes but all in harmony
just as a musical instrument resounds pleasant to the hearing of the one who listens so do your
desires you're waiting your size your tears resound to my hearing like a melody most pleasant
that's Isaiah chapter 40 verse 31 but so that it may descend more sweet and more delightful i want
to teach you another way that is to desire me not as your desire but as my desire
in other words lord i desire you because you want me to desire you it's not just me
because i greatly love to manifest myself to you in some everything you want and desire
you must want and desire because i want it that is the operative thing it's because he wants it
that is you take it from me you make it your own and in the divine will spirituality he just
opens up his divinity and says come come come inside fuse yourself with me take what you want
and then show me if you take my love what will you do with it we say oh lord i'm going to saturate
all the souls in parketry with your love i'm going to saturate all the dying with your love
so they'll surrender to you go to saturate all the unbelievers with your love so that they will
come to recognize you and acknowledge you and so on and so on he said you take it from within me
and you make it your own in this way your melody will be more delightful in my hearing
because it is a melody that has come out of myself then he added everything that comes from me
enters into me naturally he is pure spirit and he's also pure love and pure light which of course
are pure spirit this is why people complain that they don't easily get their prayers answered
well it's a wonderful lesson on that in james chapter four verse three where he says you're not
praying the right way and you're not praying for god's will you're praying for something for yourself
so if your prayer is selfish how do you expect it to be answered our prayer should be an absolutely
complete expression of love so this is why people complain that they don't obtain easily what they
ask for because those are not things that come from me jesus said and not being things that come
from me they can't easily enter into me and then come out to give themselves to them
in other words if i put my two lighted candles together it's only the two flames
that can actually mix i can't mix the wact the wactes material but the two flames are different
in fact jesus said what comes from me and enters into me is all that is wholly pure
and celestial now what's the wonder if audience is precluded to them since what they ask for is not
so it's not right therefore you should keep well in mind that all that comes from god enters into
god so louisa said i can't explain how much i understood about this how lord she said give me
the grace to ask for all that is holy and that it be your desire and your will so that you may
communicate yourself to me more abundantly so august the 19th 1900 we're talking about true love
for god this morning after i received communion my beloved jesus made himself seen in the act of
wanting to instruct me making as though an example he told me my daughter if a young man got married
and taken by love for him his wife wanted to be always with him without attaching herself for
one moment without caring about the other jesus of a wife to make this young man happy what would he
say he'd appreciate her love but he would certainly not be content with her conduct because this way
of loving would be nothing but a sterile infantile infertile love which would bring harm rather than
fruit to that young man and little by little this strange love would cause him bother rather than
delight because all the satisfaction of this love is of the young lady she's not giving anything
she's receiving as much as she can and since his sterile love has no wood with which to nourish
the fire very soon it reduces itself to ashes because only an operative love is lasting while
other loves fly into the wind like smoke and then one reaches the point of becoming annoyed and if
not caring about or even despising the one that was loved that's a rather good expression as to
why so many marriages fail in a short time in modern life where people are not looking to give
and to sacrifice themselves but only to receive such is the conduct of those souls who care only
about themselves that is they care about their own satisfaction about fervor about anything that
pleases them saying that this is love for Jesus while it's all their own satisfaction now Saint
John of the Cross has a lot to say about this in his book on the ascent of Mount Karma where he
goes into great detail to show all the sins of good people who start trying to live a spiritual life
in fact one can see from their deeds Jesus said that they don't care about God's interests
they only care about what satisfies them if what satisfies them is missing they no longer care
about me he said and they even reached the point of offending me add order only an operative love
a love that lives by giving in other words is that which distinguishes the true from the false
lovers everything else is just smoke while he was saying this I saw some people and it was as if
I wanted to pay attention to them but Jesus distracted me by saying don't meddle in other
people's business I find that fantastic coming from him because that's the language we would
use he said leave them alone because everything has its time I want to give you a proverbs 26 17
I want to give you Deuteronomy 2 5 and I want to give you Ecclesiastes 3 verses 1 to 8 there's
a time for everything time for war time for peace the time for everything okay so when the time of
judgment comes Jesus says that's one Corinthians 4 4 then will be the time to discern all things
all things will be sifted well so that one will come to recognize the grain the straws and the
sterile and noxious seeds this is described in Jesus's parable of the darndal and the wheat in Matthew 13
verses 36 to 43 oh how many things that appear to be grain will be found straws and sterile
seeds on that day were the only of being thrown into the fire that's really really sad Matthew 13
verses 30 and 50 so in other words let's not get caught on appearances because things are not what
they seem August the 20th 1900 Jesus looks at the world from within Louisa so she's a living
tabernacle one Corinthians 3 16 and one Corinthians 6 16 this morning my adorable Jesus was not
coming and then after much waiting when my poor heart could take no more he made himself seen within
my interior Luke 17 21 and he told me my daughter don't afflict yourself because you don't see me
I'm inside of you and from here through you I'm looking at the world so it's like as if she's a
tabernacle and he has a little window to look out at the world a wonderful privilege so August the
24th 1900 everything turns into good for one who loves Jesus that's Romans 8 28 having spent having
spent one day being restless Louisa said I felt all full of temptations and sins oh god what a
harrowing pain it is to offend you I did as much as I could to remain in God to resign myself to
his holy will to offer him that very restless state for love of him you see to offer it is very
important and not pay attention to the enemy who wants to keep you stirred up and wants to keep you
I wanted to show the highest indifference so that I would not incite him myself to tempt me more
but in spite of all this I couldn't help hearing a murmuring that the enemy provoked around me in
other words her problem is that she's hearing complaints through other people so finding myself
in my usual state I did not dare to desire my beloved Jesus so ugly and miserable did I see myself
but always kind to this poor sinner without my asking he came and as though sympathizing with me
he said my daughter courage don't be afraid don't you know that certain cold and mighty waters are
more powerful in purging one of the slightest spot than fire itself so fire isn't the only means of
cleansing water is also and the cold stark frostiness and snows of winter have the same effect of
purifying as the heat of the fire and then everything turns into good for the one who really loves me
so what Jesus is saying to us is relact surrender and let whatever God sends to you whether it's
cold or heat sickness or health youth or old age whatever it is success or failure it doesn't
matter what he sends that you surrender surrender surrender surrender surrender surrender surrender
surrender not my will but thine be done oh lord so august the 30th 1900 louise has to go to purgatory
to visit this king of Italy who died rather quickly so having gone through several days of
privation and bitterness at the most I saw Jesus a few times like a shadow or a flash this morning I
was at the summit of bitterness and not only this but it was as if I had lost the hope of seeing him
again then after I received communion it seemed to me that the confessor was basing the intention
of the crucifixion and blessed Jesus to let me obey made himself seen and shared his pains with
me in the meantime I saw our queen mother who taking me offered me to Jesus so that he would
placate himself and Jesus having regard for his mother accepted the offer now in higher volumes
you will be told many times that Jesus and his mother are inseparable and he finds it impossible
not to go along with what she wants so after this the queen mother said to me do you want to come
to purgatory to relieve the king of the horrible pains that he's in this guy went to purgatory
that preparation and louise said my mother as Jesus wants in an instant she took me and flying she
transported me to a place of atrocious torments all mortal she said and that miserable one that's the
king was there going from one torment to another it seemed that for as many souls as had been lost
because of him that's the bit you need to really look at so many deaths was he supposed to suffer
so while we inflict on other people we have to take responsibility for
and then after I went through several of those torments myself he seemed to be relieved a little
bit and then the queen mother took me away from this place and she said I was back to myself
now what's happening there is obviously he must have prayed to blessed mother and so blessed mother
brings him the gift of some relief to encourage him to accept his purgatory so that he can move on
to heaven so august 31st 1900 we're talking about peace and disturbance now one of the things in
volumes one to four that lord absolutely insists on is that we remain at peace inside of ourselves
and that we don't allow disturbance no matter what's going on so for peace i want to give you
Philippians four seven the peace that passes all understanding and guards the heart and the mind
in christ jesus louisa says as i was in my usual state and since my adorable jesus was not coming
i was all afflicted and a little concerned about why he wasn't coming then after much waiting and
waiting that's Isaiah 40 31 he came and seeing that blood was pouring from his hands i prayed
that from his left hand he would pour blood all over the world for sinners who were about to die
and at the risk of being lost and from his right hand that he would pour his blood over purgatory
listening to me kindly he stirred himself and poured blood in both places i want to give you
one john one seven it is the blood of jesus that saves us all and one john two verses one to two
now here louisa has given us a very simple but very powerful way of praying that we fuse ourselves
in god's holy will and god's holy love we enter into him take his precious blood make it our own
and go to the souls in purgatory and absolutely saturate them with that precious blood of jesus
but you need to do it millions of times and say to him lord i want to do this at every single moment
till i place the intention to do that so that the holy souls are receiving alleviation of their
sufferings which of course hastens their journey to god and then do it for the dying so that they
will surrender to god and receive forgiveness before they die and then do it for everybody
after this jesus said to me my daughter in the interior souls and that should be us
there cannot be disturbance and if it enters into them it is because the soul goes out of
herself that means you go out of the union with god and back into your own ego to do this is to
act as our own executioner because by going outside of herself she clings to many things that
do not regard or belong to god all that teaching is in volumes one and two and sometimes things
which do not regard even the true good of the soul so returning into herself and bringing things
that are extraneous or outside of herself she herself torments herself and with this
she comes to make herself infirm in others we weaken our spiritual life therefore remain always
within yourself and you will always become asiah 26th three and louisa said i understood this with
great clarity and i found wonderful truth in jesus words and then she asked the lord to give her
the grace to actually respond to his instruction so september the first and we're talking about
obedience september the first 1900 since jesus was still not coming i kept saying my good jesus
do not make me wait so long this morning i don't feel like getting upset which i think is very
interesting and i don't feel like looking for you so much to the point of tiring myself come once
and for all come quickly and simple it's as simple as that and in seeing that he wasn't coming i kept
saying it shows that you want me to get tired and even reach the point of getting upset otherwise
you'd come while i was saying this and other nonsense he came and he told me would you be able
to tell me what it is that maintains the correspondence between the soul and god but through a light that
came from him now that light is enlightenment or infused knowledge louisa said prayer okay so you
need to really underline that what keeps the communication between the soul and god prayer and
jesus approving of my answer said what is it that draws god to intimate conversation with the soul
louisa said she did not answer but immediately the light moved in my intellect she said and i said
if vocal prayer serves to maintain the connection certainly interior meditation must serve as
nourishment in order to maintain the conversation between god and the soul content with that jesus
continued now would you be able to tell me what it is that breaks the sweet contrasts and removes
the loving discontent which may arise between the soul and god and since she didn't answer jesus
themselves said my daughter only obedience has this office okay and so he's telling louisa
she needs to go higher with her obedience and obedience alone decides about the things pertaining
to me and the soul and when some contrasts arise or when some discontent comes to mortify the soul
as obedience arises she breaks the contrast removes the discontent and put peace between god
and the soul louisa said our lord many times it seems that obedience herself doesn't want to meddle
in it remaining indifferent and the poor soul is forced to remain in that state of contrast and
happiness and jesus said she does so for a certain time because she too wants to delight in being
present at those loving contrasts and then she assumes her office and pacifies everything therefore
obedience gives peace to the soul and to god that's asiah 26 3 so now we come to the last message
in volume three it's september the fourth 1900 and he's talking about wrong motivations so louisa
said after i received communion my adorable jesus transported me outside of myself making
himself seen highly afflicted and embittered i prayed him to pour his bitterness into me
but jesus wouldn't pay attention to me however as i insisted after a long time he pleased to pour
after he had poured a little bit of the bitterness i asked lord don't you feel better
now and he said yes but it was not what i poured that gave me so much pain rather it was a disgusting
and insipid food that doesn't let me rest and louisa said well pour a little bit into me and you'll
be relieved and he said if i can't digest and bear it he said how could you john 15 5 without me you
can do nothing louisa said i know that my weakness is great but that you would give me the grace
and the strength so that i would be able to bear it that's philippians 4 13 i can do all things in
christ who gives me the strength so i understood louisa said that the disgusting food was the
impurities and the insipid food was the good works done badly all scrambled which are rather
of bother and of weight to our lord he almost despises receiving them and unable to bear them
he wants to pour them out of his mouth who knows how many of mine are there as well
unfortunately so almost forced by me louisa said he also poured a little bit of that food
how right jesus was the bitter was more tolerable than the disgusting and insipid food
if it were not for love of him i would not have accepted it at any cost she says after this blessed
jesus placed his arm behind my neck that's song of songs to six and leaning his head on my shoulder
he placed himself in the act of wanting to take rest while he was resting i felt i was in a place
in which there were many moveable tiles and underneath them there was the abyss fearing that
i might fall i woke him up so that's mark 4 38 i woke him up invoking his help and he said to me
don't fear this is the path that everyone treads it takes nothing but all of one's attention
and since the majority walk carelessly this is why many fall into the abyss and few are those who
reach the harbor of salvation i think that is a very sad way to finish this book few indeed
reach the harbor of salvation after this he disappeared and i found myself inside of myself
so i want to give you matthew seven versus 13 to 14 that the broad way leads to hell and the narrow
way leads to heaven i want to give you revelation chapter 3 verses 14 to 22 and that is the worldly
church of leodicea that was really really warned by the spirit that while she thought everything
was fine she was dead so that's the end of volume three